[Music]
have any of you guys ever gotten so
intoxicated to the point of atomic ism
why tom is that when you [ __ ] couch
yep no it's went really is that when you
become small no when you think you're a
car oh no it's when you started texting
people is that what you think that you
have been shrunk and the entire world is
large around you break it down that
sounds more like a mushroom you're like
looking at a [ __ ] ant that's like
like two stories tall and you start
running from it oh my god blades of
grass and [ __ ] yeah
atomic ISM is the performance of actions
without conscious thought or intention
so it's like performing and voluntary
drunk that's me on absinthe only one
time pissed in a trash can and [ __ ] the
pillow front of my mom yep
any [ __ ] sand on a beach yep anyone
know well you were extremely intoxicated
violence drugs is dangerous yeah cuz uh
this guy here from Canada oh my god took
some magic mushrooms oh [ __ ]
that makes sense he got so [ __ ] crazy
that he became completely nude and it
was freezing weather tonight he ran
outside went into he broke into a
professor's home cuz this is a Calgary
University and he broken out town is
what Calgary is a lot of cows and
cowboys out there huh
we called Carter huh they do I do they
sell yeehaw yeehaw yeah hi sorry he hate
me is good he breaks them to the
professor's home while naked hi and to
beat her badly with a broom handle oh
yeah it's not funny anymore
why'd you have to say was a girl
professor I know I was thinking a guy
Torry sorry
guys getting beat up always I know but
it's a girl
especially if he's like an able-bodied
person right yeah disabled man is not
much oh did she think that she did he
think that she was a tattooing in minot
I actually would love to know what he
thought but they don't go into details
of what he was envisioning during this
whole like psychedelic trip right but
it's just that he was experiencing
delirium and he was not in control of
his action so a judge found him what
happened
he's making me laugh cuz he's laughing
what was the joke I missed it because I
was picturing a homeless crackhead it's
just a crazy thing that doesn't exist oh
it's from the Empire Strikes Back it's
fine
tattooing mine month that's Julian my
not by all anything good from Tatooine
I'm not [ __ ] I always fancied a
little math nerds did like a nerd roll
out of the loop because none of us watch
stars only the deepest nerds even know
what the [ __ ] am i knock is yeah and I
say I like Star Wars
I recognize Tatooine I didn't know what
am i an Aquos I think I put them
together ah I just like baby ordered ha
baby Yoda on the means I like baby Yoda
yeah I haven't seen any of them really
I heard it's good idea so back to it
this is uh the guy Matthew and he he was
the one that was that knew he was
beating Janet oh man the professor she
the PR professor too which is kind of
why she gotta wake up damn someone sent
Boba Fett after him right
she's a PRP boss too deep for me I know
I did
she's a peer professor she let them use
that picture projector this is the guy
again and so so the judge acquitted him
right because he's like the lawyer was
able to successfully convince everyone
that he had no control of his actions he
did not intentionally want to hurt her
and normally he's not a violent person
he's very sorry that it happened isn't
that being accused of like drunk driving
and said it was the alcohol and I killed
this person yeah that's
pretty much the same thing yeah dude
that's why it Huygens at that point
wouldn't it be like you're still
responsible enough to not get into a car
but yeah I guess but like if you got so
drunk and you got into a car that's out
of my control
yeah you know how we sometimes try when
we're putting kids in the judicial
system we kind of we try them as adults
sometimes can I be treated as a Canadian
go easy on you like me do I want to be
able to kill somebody and be like it was
the drugs that made me do it
to be clear she's not dead but I mean
like I want to do something bad and then
save the drugs
yeah living on the mushrooms yeah but
then like the family members of Janet
they're like you know we're really
disappointed because it's not like we
wanted him to get severe like oh nice
it's like we just wanted a lesson shared
with society that it's not okay to get
that I don't control it hurt people oh I
love Canada Wow I mean is there a double
standard though because if there's a
crackhead bum out there that goes out
and bites people does he get away with
it no they just release him does this
kid just go like head legends down and
RIT I got to [ __ ] pack yeah she's so
absolutely [ __ ] high exhibit a
Exhibit A Ellis [ __ ] yeah gone
he gets called to the stand his mushroom
trip can you please explain all right I
was [ __ ] oh he's like I would like to
admit into evidence the movie
transporting yeah like here's my
evidence
check out my snap story bro it's away I
don't even remember this dude
well it wasn't hurt like in my mind she
was just the demon and I had to [ __ ]
take her out he's like in my defense my
friend Brett is here yeah that guy's
[ __ ] straight up that guy was [ __ ]
up yeah cuz there were friends though
were there and they were just like he
was just not acting like himself and it
was so cold outside he just dropped them
here just standing in front of the door
and they were all right and yeah they
were this was around 3 o'clock in the
morning
I would have let you run out naked
that's pretty funny you would yeah funny
yeah but they all chased after him after
cuz they were he was just standing there
naked for the door and out of nowhere he
just bolted out and that's when they're
like oh [ __ ] they grab jackets and like
they went to go look for him they were
calling on his name and then eventually
they found him near and neighbors was
like he did break in almost like the
dark side of the force stick over here
you know that's crazy though he didn't
get in trouble at all you need a good
defense dude he's like I'll for my next
witness the defense would like to call
the Michelin Man and then there's a
man's like yeah so I guess you thought
he'd seen me in a good defense fish a
good person so you can imagine the
spirit that made me do it
you know it's crazy they mentioned that
over the course of the night he went
back into that sandwich bag of magic
mushrooms and he ate more he consumed
about 2.5 grams yeah I could tell you
that um I was once on E and I was
thinking that I wasn't on E which I was
[ __ ] completely gone on and I decided
to take more and I was high and [ __ ]
up for 48 hours and it was the most
scariest thing on earth how [ __ ] up
were you did you did you end up going to
the mall sighs the cantina did you get
by naked no I've heard but I stood up
and in my eyes went blind with when they
were open really we've got a head rush
yeah I'm glad I was tell everyone I'm
blind a permanently blind my eyes are
open
while there's lasers above you
I'm permanently blind no one was holding
me there like can you see anything and
I'm like no I'm blind for life then I'm
like oh wait
that's what the beach operating yeah
I've heard a lot of people say that
taking ecstasy makes you get by- Oh No
maybe it's just an excuse to have sex
yeah makes you horny as [ __ ] I've heard
I took your naked guy though aren't you
I I get naked when I'm drunk a lot yeah
you get naked when you're drunk I used
to just like I could just got thought it
was funny I feels comfortable too
yeah yeah so we used to have this thing
whenever PD flow would have his birthday
party
he always had a slip and slide so one
year we all got drunk birthday in the
summer
yeah no it's June so we would always one
day someone was like yo I date it's like
slip and slide naked as a joke you know
I'm saying
so it became looks good slip inside then
oh yes it's wet okay very wet don't do
it on the driveway that sucks
no no it was on the grass in his front
yard is it the crocodile my front tire
yeah yeah we were savage so uh his
neighbors in here but his dad came home
one day and to this day his dad calls me
this is a dad's nickname for me because
he comes home he's like he's like I
don't know what's going on out there
unless I was your flying yellow ass so
he called a flying yellow ass that's
time baby pants fell out no no because I
was naked naked it's like it's Archon it
was like four years of tradition
Beautiful's birthday service in the
slide we get naked incident time that's
time everyone yeah everybody me Eric P
Flo
not Rick on the front lawn on the front
lawn yeah it's just dad does his dad
look as white as P Flo does know his dad
is like super dick but no super super
thick dark super dick not super thick
dark moustache [ __ ] like dark curly
hair cuz Mexican as you can see looks
pretty Mexican yeah these are anybody in
your group that isn't famous that's like
a whole group became well-known right is
there someone else in there
didn't mean we gotta follow I mean it's
just really the four of us so I mean it
depends on who you ask I guess
yeah like is there a mystery guy that
you guys are close with but he's never
around no like the Cooper Manning you
guys would another reference yeah we let
these guys have one episode of Star Wars
and all of a sudden sometimes I can't do
this Cooper Manning is the Peyton
Manning and Eli Manning's little brother
who are other brother all these Star
Wars characters
what kind of lightsabers do they have
the green ones or the red yeah what's
that one the experienced Samuel Jackson
was the only person the only Jedi
allowed to have a purple lightsaber hey
there you go you did it that's a good
one that was he he he only agreed to be
in it if he could have a purple
lightsaber that's no yeah - magic made
George give him a purple lightsaber
everything else is red either red or
blue but he had the purple on why it was
just when you mix the colors together
that's do they have a meeting yeah red
and blue usually the red ones are the
battle points
[Music]